[Musique]
salut je vous propose de commencer par
imaginer un petit scénario voilà un pays
c'est le pays des bleus et ça ce sont
les voisins les verts il s'avère que le
pays des verts a plein de puits de
pétrole et donc il est beaucoup plus
riche est énorme et bien plus puissante
que le pays des bleus
les verts ont aussi des désirs
impérialistes alors un jour il décide de
déclarer la guerre est d'envahir le pays
des bleus
après quelques mois de conflit les verts
l'emportent et prennent le pouvoir il
laisse aux plus hauts postes les bleus
prêt à collaborer avec eux que ce soit
au gouvernement ou dans les entreprises
privées
de sorte qu'on pourrait dire que pour
une partie de la population bleus la vie
ne change pas tellement sous
l'occupation verte mais ce n'est pas
tout il faut préciser une chose
importante les verts ont carrément du
mépris voire de la haine pour les bleus
foncés une partie de la population bleu
qu'on trouve un peu partout dans le pays
une fois installé en pays bleu les verts
se mettent alors à traquer les bleu
foncé pour les mettre en prison voire
même les torturer bon voilà une
situation malheureusement assez peu
original j'imagine ce qui m'intéresse
c'est que les bleus vont réagir
différemment selon les individus les
classes etc
à un bout du spectre il ya les bleus
foncés bon bah logiquement ils vont
avoir la trouille certains vont fuir
d'autres vont se cacher d'autres vont
essayer de se faire passer pour bleu
clair d'autres encore tenteront de
prendre les armes à l'autre bout il y a
les bleus haut placé dans la hiérarchie
sociale ceux qui sont au gouvernement où
les bleus pdg de grosses entreprises ils
vont probablement pour la plupart se
plier à la politique verte et sûrement
qui se justifieront ce choix à eux mêmes
en trouvant des excuses à l'invasion
verte ou en trouvant des raisons qui
pourraient confirmer la supériorité
verte
certains iront même jusqu'à relayer le
discours vert sur les bleus foncés
entérinant ainsi leur rôle de bouc
émissaire
mais que va-t-il se passer au milieu du
spectre certains s'en doute ne seront
rien faire et détourneront leur regard
en attendant que ça passe certains
seront dans le déni relativement parce
que subissent et bleu foncé
d'autres au contraire chercheront à
s'opposer à cette invasion à cette
nouvelle situation politique et il ya
évidemment plusieurs manières de se
poser dans un cas comme celui ci le
premier exemple qui vient à l'esprit
c'est d'imaginer que certains et
certaines organiseront une résistance
est en train de continuer
clandestinement la guerre à
l'envahisseur vers soi pour défendre le
pays bleu soit par solidarité pour les
bleus foncés soit les deux et c'est en
fait intuitivement je crois que face à
une telle situation on a du mal à
imaginer une grande diversité de
réaction on se dit qu'il ya plus ou
moins trois familles ceux qui profitent
de l'invasion verte et joueront donc le
jeu volontairement ceux qui n'ont pas la
possibilité de lutter et qui font profil
bas et enfin c'est ce qu'ils considèrent
inadmissible ce qui est en train de se
passer et ne peuvent imaginer rester
sans rien faire
cette troisième famille est
nécessairement radical c'est qu'ils
reconnaissent que la situation est
radical les verts en veille pays il
craque et persécuté bleu foncé les foot
en prison sans quelque forme que ce soit
procès et vont même jusqu'à ans torturé
certains il n'y a pas de négociation
possible il faut combattre les verts et
on les comprend bien du coup un vu la
gravité ce que font les verts
imaginons maintenant une autre réaction
des bleus essayez par exemple de militer
auprès des verts pour que des bleus
foncés soient moins nombreux par cellule
en prison ou pour qu'ils aient accès à
une nourriture de meilleure qualité
qu'est ce que vous pensez de ça
a priori j'ai l'impression qu'on serait
tenté de penser un truc comme oui bon ça
part d'une bonne intention c'est sûr
c'est un élan de solidarité d'autant que
ce n'est pas une occupation très
confortable que de consacrer son temps à
essayer d'améliorer les conditions de
détention des bleus foncés mais bon en
même temps est-ce que c'est pas passer à
côté du problème est ce que ce n'est pas
au fond soigner les symptômes plutôt que
la maladie on aurait envie de dire
peut-être qu'il vaut mieux débrouillé
sur l'énergie à combattre les verts
parce que si on arrivait à renverser les
verts on pourrait régler ses problèmes
d'injustice fait aux bleus d'un coup
c'est une question de stratégie quoi il
s'agit de ne pas se tromper de problèmes
s'agit de remonter à la source ça se
défend un an bon si vous êtes d'accord
avec moi passons au scénario suivant
mais avant ça petit rappel si vous
souhaitez soutenir la chaîne est
peut-être un jour me permettre de faire
ça à temps plein abonnement cloche
commentaires partage merci
on est toujours dans le pays des bleus
ils ont fini par renverser les verts ils
ont repris le pouvoir ils ont libéré les
bleus foncés des prisons c'est cool on a
moins de 50 ans et quand on regarde le
pays bleu un peu plus précisément on
distingue plusieurs groupes de
population le ciel bleu canard bleu
marine bleu indigo bleu foncé et si on
regarde l'histoire du pays bleu on voit
que depuis super longtemps genre 500 ans
les gens qui occupent les postes les
plus importants ceux qui sont au
gouvernement qui dirige l'entreprise qui
ont beaucoup d'argent ce sont toujours
les bleu ciel
c'était déjà le cas pendant l'invasion
des verts d'ailleurs 90% des bleu ciel
avaient collaboré et seulement 1% des
résistants étaient des bleus ciel les
bleu ciel sont donc ceux qui ont le plus
d'influencé sur la manière dont le pays
fonctionne on peut dire qu'il le dirige
carrément le pays les autres bleus ont
presque accepté d'aider ils ont
l'impression que c'est normal que les
dossiers soient au pouvoir parce que ç'a
toujours été comme ça m même si on se
penche encore un peu plus précisément on
se rend compte que la manière dont le
pays fonctionne est vachement à l
avantage des bleus ciel cité bleue ciel
tu gagne plus d'argent tu as accès à des
métiers plus important plus intéressant
etc les bleu canard et des bleus marines
sont pas trop mal lotis non plus c'est
un peu plus dur pour les bleu indigo
mais le pire sans surprise c'est les
bleus foncés pour eux c'est toujours la
loose ils n'ont accès à rien
à peine de quoi manger
les bios elle raconte que dans le pays
bleu quiconque veut réussir n'a qu'à
travailler mais dans les faits comme par
hasard ce sont les enfants de bleu ciel
qui ont eu accès à des super école qui
finissent par obtenir les bonnes places
c'est logique puisque c'est la classe
dirigeante qui fixe les critères et les
bleus ciel ne se contente pas de les
céder bleu foncé dans la merde en fait
ils agissent activement pour [ __ ] des
bâtons dans les roues des bleus foncés
comment par exemple en augmentant les
prix d'éducation comme ça y'a que les
enfants de riches qui peut faire des
hautes études et ensuite grâce à leurs
diplômes avoir un boulot pas trop
pénible ou alors en augmentant le coût
des soins comme ça les pauvres ne
peuvent jamais d'argent de côté parce
que tu es qui sont malades ils
s'endettent pour survivre et puis ça
c'est quand ils peuvent s'endetter quand
ils peuvent pas ils évitent d'aller chez
le médecin ou à l'hôpital et donc ils
meurent plus tôt ah oui si on regarde on
voit que l'espérance de vie des bleus
foncés et bien plus basse que celle des
bleus clairs et chaque président élu est
issu des bleus ciel évidemment et à
chaque fois il fait des mesures qui aide
les patrons bleu ciel et les patrons
bleu ciel comme ils ont envie d'être
encore plus riche ils paient leurs
employés plus un dico le moins possible
même si le coût de la vie augmente au
bout d'un moment il ya une partie des
bleu indigo qui deviennent des bleus
foncés le nombre des bleus foncés
augmente ces gens souffrent ne savent
pas toujours s'ils pourront manger et
quand ils mangent ils mangent peu et mal
et ces gens meurent beaucoup plus tôt
avant l'âge de la retraite qui ne
connaîtront jamais et puis il ya des
bleus marines qu'ils gagnent indigo et
les bleus ciel deviennent encore plus
clair encore plus riches parce que les
bleu ciel travaillent activement à ce
que la société soit organisé en leur
faveur il travaille activement à
maintenir leur position dominante ils
sont plus riches donc plus puissant plus
influents c'est facile pour eux d'avoir
cette domination plus le temps passe que
les bleu ciel ou du pouvoir et de
l'argent et plus les bleus foncés son
pauvre et opprimé les inégalités
accroissent et c'est même une partie de
la population entière qui est opprimé
comme pour le premier scénario on peut
se demander comment la population va
réagir les bleu ciel on imagine bien
comme ils vont se comporter
ils trouveront un moyen de se justifier
le truc soit en inventant une fable qui
rend la situation juste comme la
méritocratie soir en niant la souffrance
des bleus foncés au moins en la
minimisant en tout cas il s'agira de
minimiser d'injustice les bleu canard
eux ne sont pas aussi bien passé que les
bleu ciel mais ils ont malgré tout de
bonnes raisons de croire qu'il pourrait
devenir un jour bleu ciel et ça les fait
rêver ils ont tout intérêt à avaler le
discours bleu ciel et les fables qui
vont avec parmi les bleus cana il y en a
qui sont assez intelligente et assez
sensible pour voir l'entourloupe et
avoir de la compassion pour les bleus
foncés mais ils sont tout de même trop
attachés à leur confort pour mettre leur
situation au péril ils ferment les yeux
la plupart du temps
les bleues marines dans une position
particulière il ne souffre pas tant que
ça de la situation du pays ne sont pas
super dominant mais pour diverses
raisons ils s'identifient surtout au
bleu canard c'est à cette vie qu'ils
aspirent et ils ont même le sentiment
d'y avoir droit du coup ils se
désintéressent des indigo ils ont
carrément oublié des bleus foncés
les bleu indigo sont les plus nombreux
ils ne sont pas trop favorisé par
l'organisation sociale du pays certains
s'en sortent mais la plupart galère en
un certain sens leur vie est déjà trop
plein de difficultés plus ou moins
importantes ils sont tout le temps crevé
on va pas leur demander de en plus
militer sur le peu de temps libre qu'ils
ont certains y arrivent mais on comprend
que la plupart se repose le week-end et
puis ils ont déjà l'impression à raison
que personne ne s'occupe d'eux
et puis les bleus foncés parfois se
rebiffe un peu ils manifestent ils
expriment leur mécontentement il demande
du changement il gueule quoi comment
feraient tous à leur place et en général
à ce moment là le gouvernement envoie la
police et la police réprimandé bleu
foncé et le gouvernement communique pour
discréditer les bleus foncés il n'y a
pas d' écoute pas des changes pas de
relation
le gouvernement est censé représenter
tous les bleus mais n'écoute jamais les
bleus foncés et quand les bleus foncés
en ont marre et qui foutent un peu le
bordel parce qu'il voit bien qu'on ne
les écoute jamais quand ils restent
calmes les bios elle s'indigne et le
gouvernement stigmatise un comportement
dangereux
mais alors qui fait quoi pour les bleus
foncés certains bleu canard et bleu
marine milite pour les bleus foncés il
essaie de leur obtenir des droits
sociaux ils récoltent des fonds
organisent des distributions de
nourriture c'est sympa ça part d'une
bonne intention mais ça ne change pas
grand chose c'est comme soigner les
symptômes pour la plupart ils n'arrivent
pas à imaginer ce qu'il pourrait faire
d'autre bon vous me voyez venir dans
quelle mesure est ce que cette situation
diffère de la précédente est-ce que
c'est pas un peu la même chose alors
attention il y à un risque important de
parasiter cette expérience de pensée et
ce risque c'est d'être aveuglés par la
gravité du premier scénario oui dans le
premier cas on a parlé d'emprisonnement
et de torture on se dit qu'on peut se
défendre face à un envahisseur
les verts sont venus chez les bleus et
ils ont imposé leur politique injuste ok
mais ça ne change rien de fondamental
les frontières sont des limites
arbitraires ce n'est pas parce que les
bleu ciel ne viennent pas d'un pays
extérieur qui n'ont pas exactement comme
les verts exercer leur puissance pour
asseoir leur domination sur une
catégorie de la population pour imposer
une politique injuste un bleu clair qui
rachète une usine où travaillent des
bleu foncé pour l'affirmer c'est une
forme d' invasion pour les bleu foncé
c'est leur vie leur ville leur campagne
leurs familles leurs amis qu'ils
subissent l'invasion des bleus ciel et
cette domination est maintenu et
aggraver sans aucune forme de
justification morale ou politique et des
bleus ciel s'enrichissent de plus en
plus
et les bleus foncés continue de souffrir
et mourir et en plus les bleus ciel
montrent les bleu indigo contre les
bleus foncés en fait voilà notre
question qu'il faut se poser qui fait
quoi contre les bleus ciel parce que
c'est bien une guerre qui se déroule
dans le pays bleu une guerre économique
politique et social silencieuse une
guerre qui ne dit pas son nom une guerre
qui s'invente les justifications grand
songèrent qui nie sa violence ou qu'il
est légitime arbitrairement
certains ont peut être envie de me
demander pourquoi le mot guerre bon
d'abord comme la définition de rappel
parce que c'est le bon terme on peut
faire la guerre sans prendre les armes
ensuite pour souligner la violence de ce
qui se passe on parle de faire souffrir
des gens de rendre leur vie très
difficile de raccourcir leur espérance
de vie on parle de produire des
quantités monstrueuses de malheur tout
simplement c'est un système qui favorise
une toute petite partie de la population
au détriment des autres et cette toute
petite partie de la population semble
bien vouloir défendre à tout prix le
système qui lui est favorable parce que
les bleu ciel ont le pouvoir parce
qu'ils occupent les plus hautes places
dans la société et garantissent le
maintien du statu quo dans la première
situation on se disait que c'était
millions de vouloir améliorer les
conditions de vie dans les cellules des
bleus foncés mais que tout de même la
priorité devait être de combattre les
verts
n'est ce pas la même chose ici on peut
bien donner de la nourriture de l'argent
bleu foncé mais ne faut-il pas en
priorité retirer le pouvoir au bleu ciel
autrement dit la meilleure manière
d'aider les bleus foncés n'est-elle pas
de lutter contre le système qui permet à
une catégorie de la population de
truster le pouvoir pendant 500 ans et du
coup tout de suite il faut demander
quelle forme peut prendre cette lutte
que peuvent faire les bleus foncés que
peuvent-ils faire pour se défendre pour
lutter contre cette oppression
je demande que peuvent-ils faire et on
remarque cette question à deux sens il y
a que peuvent-ils faire aux sources de
quels moyens ont-ils à disposition dans
l'absolu mais il ya aussi un autre sens
quels sont les leviers d'action dont il
dispose que la société dominante
reconnaît comme légitime parce que oui
bien sûr dans l'absolu on peut faire une
révolution avec les armes mais je
voudrais mettre de côté ce scénario là
d'abord parce que c'est un peu celui du
dernier recours donc on comprend bien qu
un tel scénario implique un changement
de paradigme
s'il y a une révolution armée ou une
guerre civile la délimitation entre ce
qui est légitime et illégitime au sein
de la société sera beaucoup plus flou
ensuite parce qu'il faut pas se leurrer
les bleus ciel on rompt l'armée avec eux
donc les bleus foncés risquerait de
perdre très gros donc que peuvent-ils
faire d'autres manifester à si on
regarde en france par exemple on
manifeste depuis aussi longtemps que je
me souvienne et on voit bien que ça ne
suffit pas à renverser la classe
dominante on peut peut-être cassé des
trucs genre manifester mais avec un
bonus destruction du matériel on a vu le
black bloc par exemple s'attaquer à des
symboles de ce système injuste en
brisant des vitrines de banques ou du
mac do avant de juger la démarche avant
de se demander si on trouve sa
pertinence juste bête ou quoi il faut
accepter de reconnaître que c'est une
expression politique c'est une manière
de faire savoir sa désapprobation quant
à la manière dont la société est
organisée
et quand on fait ça il se passe un truc
pervers
le discours officiel invalides et
discréditent cette expression politique
dans un monde rêvé le gouvernement se
dirait un truc du genre wahou les gens
pètent des trucs tellement ils sont
vénère il n'est pas impossible qu'on mrd
quelque part mais au lieu de ça il
déclare cette expression comme de la
violence illégitime et puisque c'est de
la violence illégitime c'est légitime
dans la foulée l'utilisation de la
violence par le gouvernement pour la
réprimer
évidemment les médias reprennent ce
discours à leur tour plus ou moins
explicitement sans se demander ce qui
fait naître cette violence sans jamais
laisser de place à l'idée que le premier
acte de violence n'est pas celui des
manifestants mais des bleus ciel qui
maximisent leur domination sur les bleus
foncés
et donc on entend des trucs comme on est
en démocratie merde si on veut faire
entendre sa voix on a d'autres moins que
casser des vitrines mais encore une fois
quels sont les moyens disponibles la
première réponse qui vient à l'esprit
c'est le vote mais enfin c'est pas hyper
satisfaisant comme réponse d'abord pour
désacraliser un peu le vote je vous
encourage à aller voir les deux vidéos
que le camarade patchwork a consacré au
sujet ensuite je voudrais rappeler deux
trois petites choses pouvoir voter c'est
chouette bien sûr mais ça n'existe pas
un vote ou une voie par exemple on sait
que pour un même nombre de voix le
résultat de l'élection change selon le
type de scrutin donc dire c'est bon on
peut voter et on est dans un pays libre
c'est un peu court comment sait-on que
notre mode de scrutin est juste en
france on ne connaît pas le vote blanc
ou nul donc tu peux côté mais si tu veux
au moment les élections exprimé son
désaccord si tu veux faire entendre sa
désapprobation vis-à-vis des politiques
proposées par les candidats et
candidates battue peut pas donc
discréditer les manifestations sous
prétexte qu'on a le vote pour exprimer
son opinion bof et puis que penser des
élections dans un pays où les
journalistes et les médias ont autant de
pouvoir ce sont eux qui posent des
questions qui répondent aux candidats
regardez laurent delahousse bonsoir
monsieur le président bonsoir on est
dans votre bureau ou dans l'un de vos
bureaux il ya quelques minutes on m'a
dit que c'était pas toujours le même
bureau vous avez plusieurs bureaux à
l'étagé deux bureaux à l'elysée j'ai
envie de vous poser une question est ce
que vous y passez finalement beaucoup de
temps dans ce ou ces bureaux oui oui on
passe beaucoup de temps à travailler les
dossiers de fond y compris d'ailleurs
les week-ends la nuit on dit oui aussi
beaucoup oui c'est pas une légende n'ont
finalement dormait très peu je dors peu
mais j'ai toujours peu dormi donc ça
nous coûte très peu de temps avait
découvert le candidat en marche on a
découvert un président mâcon qui courent
vous courez beaucoup depuis sept mois
et ses journalistes ils sont soit bleu
ciel soit bleu canard si vous n'avez pas
déjà vu je vous invite à regarder le
documentaire les nouveaux chiens de
garde on y mentionne par exemple le
dîner du siècle où l'élite se retrouvent
une fois par mois les bleus ciel de
france en somme et bien sûr on y trouve
plein de journalistes sans entrer dans
les détails on ne manque pas d'exemples
de journalistes qui protège le système
en place cette vidéo de déflecteurs par
exemple en est plein
je ne résiste pas à m'attarder une
seconde sur un cas particulier quand
thomas piketty est invité à france inter
et qu'il parle de ses propositions sur
les droits de succession nicolas
demorand et léa salamé lui tombe dessus
sans la moindre nuance sans rien écouté
à ce qu'il propose alors même qu'il est
évidemment bien plus calés sur le sujet
que et donc sans ouvrir le débat à la
discussion il lui aboie dessus pour
former le débat d'abord est-ce que vous
êtes sûr qu en éradiquant les 1% les
plus riches d'une certaine manière est
ce que vous êtes sûr que tout ira mieux
véritablement est-ce que vous ne tombez
pas dans le du bouc émissaire tout le
monde partira à l'aller les très riches
quitteront la france du jour au
lendemain terminer si on passe à 90 % en
ont arrêté de faire
s'agissait d'abord à contradictoires sur
ce que vous dites ça n'a aucun intérêt
bien de savoir si vous l'avez doit
peut-être peut-être c'est la question
vous posez les à un rapport de type
boucs émissaires à cette fraction de la
population pas du tout ça ira mieux une
fois qu'ils se répéter une fois qu'ils
ont plus la doma piketty furet des
riches un bouc émissaire et bouc
émissaire c'est une expression
rhétorique pour discréditer une position
si votre discours implique un bouc
émissaire alors vous êtes injuste du
coup l'analyse de thomas piketty est
immédiatement invalidée il est coupable
d'une erreur politique définitive et
c'est piketty dont on parle hein c'est
pas un révolutionnaire bon quand ils
reçoivent lyrique zemmour et qui lui
pose des questions sur l'immigration on
lui dit pas qu'il fait des musulmans un
bouc émissaire on lui demande de
préciser les chiffres et arrêter les
flux et maître l'immigration à 0
aujourd'hui et depuis des années ya à
peu près de 150 me très simple vous êtes
élu président combien y aura-t-il de
titre de séjour chaque année combien
d'immigrés pourront entrer en france
donner un chiffre j'arrive à combien
alors pour finir quel 175000 aujourd'hui
je vous dis je vous vous rendez compte
de la responsabilité morale de ces gens
là vous vous rendez compte de la gravité
de leur attitude un économiste a osé
mettre en péril les fondations du
système qui maintiennent la domination
des bleus ciel il doit être fou on le
serait à l'écouté c'est trop dingue
prendre de l'argent aux riches mais
quelle violence
comment voulez vous que les bourgeois
remettent en question leurs positions et
le système qui les favorise si les
médias se comportent ainsi comme disait
marc richer il paraît plus facile
d'imaginer la fin du monde que la fin du
capitalisme et le pire c'est que ça
passe taubira par exemple veut relever
le seuil d'impôts sur les droits de
succession tout le monde fait comme s'il
était dans l'intérêt de toute la
population de protéger les bleus ciel
que reste-t-il à une population qui
subit cette domination comme levier pour
lutter comment une idéologie aussi
inégalitaire peut-elle s'installer et
dominer tout un pays c'est une vaste
question à laquelle je ne peux
évidemment pas répondre ici ça suppose
de combiner plusieurs angles historique
sociologique anthropologique
logique sémiologique philosophique et je
ne veux pas donner une réponse au rabais
mais je ne veux pas non plus que la
difficulté de la question occulte la
gravité de l'injustice ce que je vois
c'est une culture qui semble promettre à
tout le monde la possibilité du succès
et de la richesse et qui fait de cet
objectif un accomplissement individuels
comme une grande compétition dans les
films les séries et les clips sur les
réseaux sociaux on ne voit que ça du
luxe des belles voitures et des gens
riches et oui du coup j'imagine que ça
ne favorise pas l'identification à une
population dominé on ne s'identifie pas
à un groupe et encore moins à un groupe
qui souffre parce qu'on serait unique
spécial à part parce qu'on nous dit
qu'une vie réussie c'est une vie où on
n'a plus réussi que les autres ça
empêche l'émergence d'une conscience de
classe ça empêche de sentiments de
solidarité d'où la méga arnaque de la
méritocratie qu'on avait abordé dans
cette vidéo la
lécher les jaunes portait justement cet
espoir d'un rassemblement populaire on a
vu comment le pouvoir les a traités on
peut pas dire qu'ils ont été supers
soutenu et n'oublions pas on ne devient
pas riche sans profiter d'un système qui
crée des pauvres qui créent de
l'injustice certains diront que mon
propos est caricatural je ne crois pas
schématique oui mais pas caricatural
rappelons que le nombre de sdf augmente
constamment tiens regardez cette
infographie vertigineuse réalisé pour
visualiser la fortune de jeff bezos ce
là ce tout petit point c'est 1000 $ se
caresser 68 mille dollars le revenu
médian d'une famille aux usa
ça c'est un million de dollars
salah c'est un milliard de dollars et ça
c'est la fortune de ben et dos au moment
où cette infographie et fait il est à
168 milliards
ça ne s'arrête pas
vous voyez les curseurs en bas à gauche
ça vous donne une idée de la tête du
truc
je vous encourage à aller voir plus loin
dans l'infographie on nous présente des
points de comparaison
ne croyez pas que ça n'arrive qu'aux
états unis nous aussi on a notre bezos
berne un homme le mec est à 158
milliards
autre mise en perspective si vous
arriviez à mettre 1000 euros de côté par
jour il vous faudrait à peu près quatre
cent quarante mille ans pour atteindre
sa fortune
alors rappelez vous de macron ministre
de l'économie qui annonce que chaque
jeune devrait vouloir devenir
milliardaire par définition ils ne
pourront pas tous le devenir ils ne
pourront même pas tous devenir
millionnaire ni même riche tout
simplement c'est donc une manière de
cautionner une compétition brutale qui
créent des pauvres pour faire des ultra
méga riches et rappelez-vous du poids
que représentent les riches dans le
réchauffement climatique c'est la
planète de nos enfants à tous que les
bleu ciel détruit sans hésiter et
attention j'ai mis l'accent sur la
dimension économique de cette guerre
mais les dominants ne font pas seulement
la guerre aux pauvres ils la font aussi
aux femmes aux homosexuels aux trans
aura 6 et aux handicapés aux personnes
grosses c'est la guerre
tous les jours sous nos yeux et tout est
fait pour qu'on les garde fermée